fencing is like a chess game all the
strategies and tactics matters
honest answers is whip that guy
whip his ass i'm sorry
hi gq this is jackson wang and today
i'll be going undercover
on internet
[Music]
this is actually me twitter
quick question have you ever had a brain
error while trying to speak different
languages
this is the thing i speak a lot of
different languages but
i'm not pro in any of them it's enough
for me to live
in that region but if you tell me to
write an
essay i'm sorry what's your biggest fear
in life cockroaches and uh when i turn
off my light in my bedroom
okay next will your new songs have a
few chinese and english ones
i'll be releasing one english album this
year
and a chinese album hopefully yeah it's
over 40 songs this year
next question what's the real color of
your hair
very dark brown you mean since day one
cause i don't know
next time ask my mom
i am db nickname wang puppy
that's what a lot of my fans call me
they think that i'm i'm like a little
puppy i have a lot of different
nicknames they call me sunni
and they call me they call me strawberry
and they call me uh
daddy wikipedia
he was offered a scholarship to stanford
university for fencing but turned it
down after passing his audition
yes it's true i turned stanford
university
and i turned london olympics
down for uh becoming a
singer as a child my my my dad
is a former olympian offenser and uh my
mom's a
world champ gymnast so grew up naturally
introduced to sport
but i just thought i'm probably going to
regret when i'm 80 years old
and telling my grandkids hey you know
what your granddad
your grandpa you could have been a
singer it could have been
this could have been that i didn't want
that regret so
just gave it a try i said let's start
from nothing
back to twitter jackson i have a
question what language is set for your
phone korean chinese or english uh it's
english
but like different applications i use
like different language
some in korean some in chinese yeah from
interrupting your fencing
career to starting your own company you
have made some risky decisions what is
your process of making such big
decisions
i think it's very important in life to
know yourself what you love
what you have passion in what are you
into right after knowing yourself
start making plans towards it and along
the path
you have to take risk in order to be
whoever you want to be or accomplish
your mission your dream
you can't have everything so you got to
give up on some
something quora
how do i become a kpop star if i'm not
korean
you don't have to be korean to become a
k-pop star i think a lot of different
entertainment companies goes to
different countries territories to cast
people if you're really interested and
if you're really dedicated then
why not give it a try and go to one of
the um
edition a lot of online auditions are
happening
give it a try i'm chinese so you don't
have to be korean to become a k-pop star
how does jackson want know kevin hart
through a friend their friend
and been a big fan of him and
love all his work and really respect him
as an artist
next which country did jacksonville want
to visit
any country every country every country
on earth
more twitter what did you want to be
when you were a kid instead of fencing i
wanted to become
a peacemaker in primary school making
peace so when whoever gets into a fight
i'll be there hey you stop you stop
shake hands hug each other
be friends it seems most successful
people meditate
and i believe you do too would you share
what is your
meditation routine getting enough sleep
which i don't actually i don't have a
meditation routine
what is your skin care routine first of
all
i wash my face the very last in the
shower routine
because shampoo and conditioner
it actually irritates your skin that's
why i wash my face at last
and after i wash it i put on toner
and then essence and moisturizer
when i go out in the morning i always
put sunscreen
and at night i put sleeping pack and
every morning when i wake up i do like a
mask pack
that's my skincare routine and always
eat salads vegetables
greens fruits i don't know if it's even
a question but how can you keep
motivating yourself
i've been struggling a lot this year and
this is so difficult to stay motivated
uh when everything goes down can you
give me a little tip to feel better
several major reason that's keeping me
motivated and passionate every day is
first of all
all the people that supports me you know
my fans
and that really gives me a lot of energy
right i've always wanted to make whoever
supports me proud
that's the first main reason and then
the second
would be because i'm very clear on my
goals in life and also where i want to
go and how
can i go every single day i'm trying to
accomplish it
i'm always not satisfied with myself
that's why i think
i always want to be better next what do
you love to do in your free time
first of all probably uh record more
songs
sleep calm my parents thank you guys
that's all for the questions i love you
guys so much take care of yourself
i'm signing off the internet